MIMI FOX MELTON: Hi.
I'm Mimi Fox Melton, director
of Technical Applicant Prep
Programs at CODE2040.
CODE2040 is a San
Francisco-based non-profit
that creates pathways to
success in the innovation
economy for blacks and Latinos.
Right now, there is a huge
wealth gap in this country.
And it's impacting our
communities, our businesses,
and our economy, especially
as our country's demographics
continue to shift.
However, the new
tech economy also
presents a huge
opportunity, especially
for those of us in
the tech industry.
We have the power to
change the face of tech
and close this wealth gap.
So here's what we're doing.
We have four programs exploring
pathways to increase access
into the tech sector.
I came on board to build
out our TAP programs
and answer the
question, how do we
reach every single black
and Latino computer science
major in the country?
You may already be familiar
with our summer Fellows
program, which started in
2012 with five students.
This summer, we're
growing to 80 students
who snag paid summer internships
at top Bay Area tech companies.
Despite efforts like
these as an industry,
we haven't made
significant gains
towards increasing diversity.
Though in the US,
blacks and Latinos
make up 28% of the population
and 18% of computer science
degrees, we're only represented
in tech at 5% to 9%.
Through the Fellows
program, we've
worked with over
70 companies who
are taking action towards
building more diverse teams
and exploring and implementing
operational and cultural
changes to retain those
diverse team members.
Our Fellows program
successes are
enabling us to tackle
that question, how do we
support the 32,000 black
and Latino computer science
majors in the US who are
struggling to survive
as first generation college
students, immigrants, or women
of color?
In 2015, my team launched
a series of workshops,
webinars, and local
retreats designed
to build professional
development skills
and community for
those 32,000 students.
We piloted with about 600
students, and we learned a lot.
At the end of the
year, I hit the books
to analyze our surveys, review
our focus group data, interview
volunteers and
university faculty,
and read every study I
could find on the minority
experience in CS.
What I found was staggering.
The overall dropout rate
for CS students in the US
is around 30%.
For blacks and Latinos, that
number jumps to around 70%.
One historically black
college in the US
reports an annual
dropout rate of 96%.
The data show four reasons why
students of color drop out.
I talk to students
all the time who
don't know a single
other black or Latino
person in their major.
They don't know that
they can start a company,
make a lot of money, or change
the world with their degree.
We hear from students
dealing with depression,
diminished self-worth, and
intense imposter syndrome.
At best, some of them suffer
through it and graduate.
The vast majority change majors,
and some drop out of school
entirely.
I believe that there's
a fourth option,
a space where black and
Latino students are thriving.
They understand their
potential in the industry,
and they see a clear path
to achieving their goals.
I created TAP 2016
to be that program.
TAP 2016 is a year-long program
with in-person and virtual
engagement designed to
connect computer science
and academia with software
engineering careers.
As part of TAP 2016, we're
launching a new initiative,
First Years on Campus, which
is an early intervention cohort
program for black and Latino CS
freshman, designed especially
for programming that address
those common causes of CS
dropout.
We are constantly asked by
techies, what can I do to help?
So we're building out our
professional leadership
development work with our
alumni and our volunteers,
specifically to expand their
mentorship and facilitation
skills.
So whether you work
with us or someone else,
it is vital that you, as an
individual, get involved.
Reach out to us and
apply the volunteer.
Design a webinar, sit on a
panel, or write a blog post.
We'll help.
Let us know that you can
give a tour of your office
or even have a student
shadow you for a day.
We are always in need
of virtual coaches
who can give resume feedback,
general career advice,
or practice interview skills.
We can help you pitch an
internship at your organization
or in your department.
This summer, you can mentor
a fellow for eight weeks.
Introduce them to your
network, invite them
to your office-- you know,
just spend your time with them.
Look, this is not a problem
that people of color
alone are going to
be able to solve.
This is an all-hands-on-deck,
America-is-in-trouble kind
of problem.
But there is action
that you can take today
to make a difference.
Email us and let us
know that you're in.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]